all right so what it was like Chris
Texas oh yeah no no I don't trust them
no I wouldn't yeah because you know what
you don't know me that cuz I would be a
good guy about this no because I've left
my phone in the main room and you've I
have a rule you've but I have a rule but
now I have a code I never just do the co
and I have a rule about it right so you
used to do Instagram and Twitter and
like all that all yeah yeah and you know
why what I guess I'm a rule
so are you around I'll tell you the
rules look here's the here's the [ __ ]
man I like to laugh I like to have a
silly good time
I'm down for a silly goose time and
that's it dude what's a silly goose time
like a silly goose time silly goose like
we're silly goose
oh yeah yeah geez yeah yeah you don't
get it cuz you're from [ __ ] North
Korea yeah but not the same are you are
you Andrew Santino right now what do you
[ __ ] mean do because he provokes me
ethnically as well well don't provoke me
ethnically so what do I say about her
are you around he did this today at 8:45
in the morning yeah oh dude yeah I put
in yeah Ian's around you know how I do
it yeah yeah what you got a misspelled
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah tell me what tell me
what to say okay you say yeah sorry
sorry SOR ry yeah sorry yeah sorry
let's misspell something I'm around I am
around and then put now and then put a
be at the end of now a robbed okay
around no more I'm around and to put a
beat yeah the back yeah now but because
here's the thing if you text back and
there's a spelling mistake
it's a [ __ ] subtle way of saying this
is my house all right all right I didn't
check how can I add something yeah what
yeah I'm around and I'll just put a zero
here just think and then I just do that
so look yeah sorry I'm around B and then
the Z let me see it
I'll show you now busy there you go
I'm around to visit and they can I put
it has some sort of like so yes all
right I'm around Z like you're on the
treadmill
yeah the treadmill I'm sorry yeah yeah
it's better when you when it seems like
you're just kind of like you're like oh
I put it B in there half [ __ ] cent
that I didn't check it you know I mean
yeah you're on the move can I also say
something about us about what but my
rule is but my rule [ __ ] this is my bad
chill we're going back to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah if I'm down first so the good
time and that's it okay now if you leave
your phone out unattended with no code
on it yeah and you look the other way
and I got a spot to have a [ __ ] silly
goose time if there's a [ __ ] moment
in time where I could take this [ __ ]
time from a regular time and [ __ ]
raise it up to a silly goose time yeah
I'm gonna grab your phone and tweet out
some [ __ ] yeah do you know why why cuz
that's your ass [ __ ] left the phone
up right you left the phone out now if I
know the code and your phone is locked
yeah I won't do it because you locked
your phone like a [ __ ] human is
supposed to do it I'm gonna tell you my
code I don't want to know the code I
want to tell you what anyway it's two
two two two two two two
okay well I'll tell you this what if you
leave it long would it leave it life
still won't unlock it leave it unlocked
I'll still [ __ ] ask you know Chris let
me ask you a question okay what all
right you think when geese is hanging
out yeah and they're having a goofy time
yeah they're having a silly human time I
don't know dude
that's like some [ __ ] 90s comedy
when I threw it out there tonight man I
stood out that you did it yeah shut up
in its word yeah yeah it's a good one
huh
[Music]